welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
CRISPR chip detection of unamplified
target genes via CRISPR cas9 immobilized
on graphing biosensors it is presented
by dr. Kiana Iran who is the co-founder
of Nano sends an assistant professor of
biomedical sciences at the Keck Graduate
Institute and a visiting assistant
professor at UC Berkeley
my name is 2b O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now that further ado please join
me in welcoming dr. around I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you very much for the introduction
before I start talking about our
technology and why we decided to combine
CRISPR an electronic system I would like
to just talk about our vision and why
we're interested in merging biology and
electronic with all the successful
technological advances that we have had
in electronic system and gadgets in
terms of size speed accessibility cost
if we can tailor this electronic system
for healthcare application we can really
transform healthcare in healthcare
industry can we actually use these
technological advancements and designs
simple and easy to use biosensors for
healthcare application where you can
have easy
your health information now if we can
leverage the existing biology and
existing assays and we unmerge those
with electronic biosensors then we can
bring this system to market much faster
and really start using them and if we
were successful then we can then we can
scale scale this system that we can
actually have a lot of people use this
system for their health care information
for their health information and we can
make the system more accessible without
the need for a skilled personnel or a
specialized space in addition if you're
using digital system you can you can do
multiplexing because because because of
the advancement in size of these systems
that we have we have been able to get to
very very small sizes we can design
multiplex system on a very small scales
so that will allow us to to to process
large volume of information and collect
large large volume of information we can
also analyze the data much easier using
the systems so why is this important it
is well understood by biologists and
researchers and scientists that if we
want to really understand the underlying
processes of diseases looking at a
single biomarker is not enough we need
to look at proteomics we need to look at
genomics we need to be able to process
this data and and make predictive
analysis of why why these are important
in in disease processes so if you think
about it you're gonna have to deal with
a large volume of data and without
digital platform it's going to be very
difficult to process this large volume
of data to actually send them to
algorithm where they can be analyzed and
predictive analysis can be made so
sensors and electronic sensor in that
aspect would be very beneficial because
we can seamlessly collect many data we
can seamlessly transfer this data to up
to algorithms and analyze them and make
medical novices in terms of nucleic acid
detection I mention
that if we can leverage the existing
biology would make it would be easier to
actually take the system to commercial
application and real real use but in
terms of nucleic acid detection
leveraging the existing biology I'm
merging them with electronic it's a
little bit challenging there isn't 4
that is existing assay on biology such
as next-gen sequencing there
amplifications are difficult to bring on
electronic by sensors and devices
although we can address problems like
portability costs speed and multiplexing
with digital sensors we still have to
deal with complex primary designs and
some of these amplification physiology
they require more than one enzymes so
that then we have to make sure that the
assays that we're developing are
applicable for both enzymes I mean that
both enzymes can can work perfectly in
that environment we have to optimize
this assay significantly then we have to
deal with reagent and we have to bring
this reagent or biological systems and
we also have lowest low single base say
single base burn specificity in this
system so there's still be a lot of
complexity if we're going to merge this
system with with electronic devices
merges assays electronic devices what
really we really want we want a real
simple system very similar to the search
function that we have in our computers
when you hit control up in your computer
you can actually search for for any type
of word that you're looking for you just
put that word in the search box and the
search function will search through your
document and you'll find it for you and
then you can edit or change it or do
whatever you want to do with it it's
it's it's that simple of a system that
we're looking for how can we design
something that's simple that that can
help us design simple digital biosensors
something that that can do the search
function as simple as a control F on our
computers if you look at CRISPR CRISPR
is a two component system it consists of
a caste
enzyme and in the nucleus and a guide
RNA together this complex CRISPR can
unzip the double-stranded DNA search for
its target molecule or to target a
strand find it and then it cuts it and
after that we can do editing so if you
look at it the main function of CRISPR
it's it's searching the main the most
powerful aspect of CRISPR it's a search
function it's very similar to the
control of on our computer you can
actually program the guide RNA to find
and search for any target molecules that
we're looking for so can we actually use
this biological search engine in our
system so if we can actually monitor
CRISPR activity we can we can
potentially design a simple system that
utilizes the CRISPR search function and
find the target molecules that we're
looking for it is important that we take
into account that the power of CRISPR as
compared to other gene editing
technologies it's its simplicity because
you can easily reprogram this dis
complex to target and find any nucleic
acid or any sequence that you're looking
for so we don't want to take away the
simplicity of this system it's also a
very versatile system because you have
the ability to simply reprogram it by
changing the guide RNA is strand to
target a different gene so we really
want to design a system that maintains
the simplicity and harness the pre
programming capability of CRISPR and
merge it with electronic so in order to
do that the best systems are filled
effect transistors because these are
these are label free system if you look
at the picture on the right you can see
how the system look like these are
basically three terminal devices you
have source drain and gate the current
that you see here between the soap and
the drain which run
through a semiconductor material mostly
silicon is used it's it's controlled by
the gate voltage so now if you consider
the gate voltage to be constant the
current which is shown as IDs here in
this picture depends on the
semiconductor property semiconductor
electronic property so now if you can
adhere or attach charge molecule to this
semiconductor and you will change the
property under constant gate voltage
you'll change the property of this
semiconductor so the IDs or other
electronic parameter of this transistor
would change which can be monitored
without any labels and very quickly so
if we can bind our crispr complex to our
semiconductor for example silicon here
and monitor it when it binds or it
interacts with its DNA forget then we
can monitor this activities because DNA
is a charged molecule so it affects the
semiconductor property and the
electrical property of of silicon so we
can actually use the simplicity of the
system and not and not lose the CRISPR
simplicity in our system in addition we
can make millions of these transistors
in a small space in a single chip so
that will enable us to the versatility
of CRISPR where you can actually
functionalize each of this transistor to
target a specific gene so now you can
actually have you can actually monitor a
different region in enlarge in large
genes using this multiplex systems made
of these transistors although this is a
very powerful system and basically you
have a label-free transistor label for
label free detection and CRISPR but
silicon material itself is not very
sensitive that means that we may not be
able to see the interaction of the
castes or the CRISPR complex with the
target in order to improve that we use
graphing so graphene is a 2d material
made from
a single layer of carbon molecules it is
super sensitive to the molecules
especially charged molecules like our
DNA or like proteins that are attached
to it or even if they come across it you
will see the change in electrical
property so if instead of silicon in our
field effect transistors we use graphene
we can enhance the sensitivity of sis
dramatically so now if we can adhere our
our TAS enzyme to graphene we can
basically get the same property as a
silicone-based fold effect transistor
but with significantly higher
sensitivity in addition we can easily
attach things to graphene I can attach
proteins we can attach enzymes we can
attach nucleic acid to graphene and then
this is protein or disk capturing
molecules it then they can interact with
your target which in our case will be
immobilizing CRISPR on graphene and
having it interact with DNA and I think
the DNA comes close to the surface then
you can monitor the activity on the
surface of the graphene so this is
exactly what we did we combined CRISPR
which field effect transistors and we
made our field effect transistors from
graphene biosensors from graphene
material so there is a video here that
can show you how how the CRISPR complex
works CRISPR chip can detect the target
DNA using a handheld reader developed by
the team's industrial collaborators the
surface of the grafting material within
the CRISPR chip transistors are
decorated with thousands of CRISPR
complexes that are anchored to the
graphing using chemical linkers
after the introduction of the
unamplified DNA on to the CRISPR chip
transistors these DNA molecules travel
down to the surface of the chip where
they are scanned by CRISPR complexes
CRISPR unzips the double-stranded DNA
and searches for its target if it
doesn't find its target the DNA is
released without further interaction
however if the CRISPR finds its target
sequence it will bind to the DNA this
binding changes the conductivity of the
graphing material which is ultra
sensitive to the absorption of charged
molecules at its surface
this complex generates a signal which
can be detected rapidly with the CRISPR
chip configuration so just to recap on
the video we have our CRISPR chips which
is decorated with with thousands of
CRISPR molecule on its surface once we
introduce our DNA sample and this is
basically provide DNA sample not an
optic on to our graphene surface in our
CRISPR chip if the CRISPR complex find
its target then it will bind to it and
this binding will change the electrical
property of the graphene which we can
sense immediately with or with our
reader so here you can see how the chip
is basically fabricated you have you
have basically again a field effect
transistors which have your source and
drain electrode the graphene is placed
between the source and drain electrode
and then you have your gate terminal
which is inserted in the liquid the way
we fabricate this system we used to
purchase graphene chips from from
commercially available vendors we used
to make our pattern it and make our
transistors and as you can see then if
you wanted to do multiplexing we would
have multiple of these systems connected
to our to our readers and we would read
from them although this was
these are very powerful sensors and very
sensitive systems but it's fabrication
of them were very time-consuming and it
was not something that we thought it
would be scalable but later on we start
collaborating with our industrial
partner cardio bio which they were
specialized in mass fabrication of
graphene chips so we start using their
graphene sensor and that helped us
progress in our research significantly
faster so we had a system that was very
close to a commercial product so the
system as you can see in this figure
here the graphene sensor is is
functionalized with
with CRISPR complex basically we have a
linker molecules the linker molecule
it's bound or CRISPR complex and then
we'll introduce our sample to CRISPR
chip functionally the functionalization
process is shown here in this figure you
have the Naked graphene in Figure a and
B we immobilize or linker molecule the
linker molecule has from one end binds
to the graphene sensors and from the
other and it binds to the caste nine
enzyme in our case we used the activated
enzyme because we just want to bind we
don't want to cut the sequence and then
we introduced our guide RNA so the
process is basically first immobilizing
the graphene immobilizing the complex on
the graphene then we passivate or chip
to make sure that we don't have any
naked graphene surface left because then
they can interact not specifically with
our target with our biological sample
and then we calibrate our sensors and
then we do we do our measurements the
important thing is that with our readers
and all we have the capability to
actually monitor these events in real
time from the minute that we we place
our linker molecule on the surface from
where we actually functional eyes or
sensors with the with the cast enzymes
passivation binding guide RNA and then
interaction with the DNA these are all
can be monitored in our system which
enable us to do other applications which
I'll talk about later with christian
research
not only diagnostics so here you can see
the sensor response in presence of
amplicon so as you see in this graph we
tested our sensor in presence of a blue
fluorescence protein and amplicon that
contains new fluorescence protein
genome in it so if you see in this in
this case the drmp scram shows a CRISPR
chip that was functionalized with a with
a CRISPR complex that had the guide RNA
that was not a specific toward new
fluorescence protein gene whereas the
drmp BFP was a CRISPR chip that was
functionalized with a guide RNA that was
very specific to blue fluorescence
protein gene and you see our sensor can
significantly tell you that the binding
and their sensor response in presence of
a target was significantly higher than
when you did not have the right guide
RNA so this by itself will enable you to
actually validate the guys well if
you're using software to design your
guys then you can use our complex to
actually see if the guys that your
purchase or the guys that you have are
working on your applicants in addition
we tested our sensor with with whole
genomic sample that means that there was
no amplicons we basically just purified
genomic material and we tested it in our
CRISPR chip as you see the sensor
response was very specific to the
concentration of the material that we
introduced to them to the sensors so
here again we use blue fluorescence
protein but this time you used the whole
genomic sample that contained the blue
fluorescence gene and after introduction
introducing them the genomic material to
this CRISPR chip and washing we can see
that the sensor response also correlated
with the amount of genomic material that
we placed on the sensor and this was
done without amplification we also
tested our sensor in presence and
absence of contamination here you see in
this graph you see when we test
answering
presence of genomic material that did
not contain blue fluorescence protein
basically very similar to the other
genomic material one had the blue
fluorescence protein and the other did
not have and our sensor response was
also was also very good we did a lot of
chip optimization for these processes
this include efficient functionalization
buffer conditions and assay times we did
appropriate calibration and also we have
to make sure that we use the right
molecule to passivate our our graphene
chips however we haven't done crisper
surface crisper modern optimization
where we can actually change the density
of crisper molecules on our crisper
chips see how that affects them range
and our limit of detection and limit of
quantifications
and also we can also further work with
with graphene geometry in our chip to
enhance our sensitivity we later on move
to actually use clinical sample to see
how our sensor was responding in
presence of clinical sample wait for the
first sample we used genomic material
from Duchenne muscular dystrophy
so the dystrophin gene is the largest
gene in human body and the disease can
happen if you have deletion in any of
the exon basically 79 exon if you have
deletion in any other exons between exon
1 to 79 then you have you're prone to
this disease so we did for our CRISPR
shape design we first obtain samples
from patients that had deletion in exon
3 so basically the patient a B and C had
deletion that contain deletion of exon 3
patient de and F had deletion that
contain exon 51 we designed to CRISPR 1
CRISPR chip was targeting exon 3 and
other CRISPR chip was targeting exon 51
in this graph you see the sensor
responded so this is basically a CRISPR
chip that was designed to target exon 3
h1 h2 and h3 or healthy sample obtained
from patient that did not have
muscular dystrophy and as you see
because this patient all had eggs on
three the sensor respond was positive
however because sample a B and C were
lacking the eggs on three the sensor
respond was negative for sample de NF
because this patient had eggs on three
but did not have exam 51 we were also
getting positive response we had the
sample D is a is a false negative and it
was also validated with sequencing the
graph on the right now shows that CRISPR
chip that was designed to target exon 51
as you see for healthy patient at one H
2 and s 3 and and patient a B and C
which had exon 51 the sensor respond was
positive however for sample de NF
because they were lacking exam 51 the
sample the CRISPR chip respond was
negative for our threshold we use the
highest concentration of genomic
material that you could obtain from a
single book also up about 2.5 microgram
of genomic material there was non target
material and basically we designed our
negative threshold based on that in
addition we monitor so that we monitored
the chip reproducibility so that the
orange bar graph that you see on top
here that shows the the sensor response
and chip-to-chip variation and we also
did concentration variation and the
linear response is shown in the graph so
as you can see for you can easily design
a system that can target all of these 79
exon you can have a multiplex transistor
each of these transistor can target one
of these genes or a region of these
genes and then when you run this genomic
sample on our transistor you can you can
easily identify which region of these
exons are deleted for this specific
disease for for genetically inherited
disease we actually do need PCR the
system was able to actually detect the
is a deletion without the PCR we
understand that for many application you
may need PCR such as infectious disease
where you have very low concentration of
your target but for some application you
really do not need to run PCR and that's
one example of it we are currently
running experiment with sickle cell
disease sickle cell is kind of it's more
difficult to detect because it's single
point mutation with muscular dystrophy
was big big deletion but with with
sickle cell disease the healthy and
diseased genetic material they only
differ in a single single single
basement so our our result here was in
presence of amplicons and you can see
here with when we designed a CRISPR trip
that had that was the targeting the
healthy the healthy HPB sequence we were
able to get high response in presence of
the healthy samples feasel healthy
amplicons from healthy patients and SCD
one and SCD two were diseased patient
and we're not getting a similar response
in those although there are single point
mutation and if you had a scram guide i
guess that means that it was a if you
use the guy that was not a specific to
any of these the target sequences you
want you won't get a significant
response so we're currently running the
system on an unfilled anomic material
and we're also getting very promising
results from from the system so as I
mentioned diagnostic is not the only
application of CRISPR chip you can
monitor CRISPR binding efficiency as I
showed you when you actually design your
guides using the software's online
softwares we can actually validate your
applicants instead of running gels and
gel electrophoresis you can actually use
our system and this will give you a much
quicker response if your if your guide
aren't any actually binding or cleaving
or doing anything with your amplicons
we can also test the same the same guys
on purified DNA to see if the the the
CRISPR complex that you're designing
actually it does interact with with your
DNA or whole genomic sample in addition
we're really interested in monitoring
CRISPR binding efficiency in chromatins
because it's shown that casts 9 binding
and cutting is really inhibited by
chromatin so if your target sequence is
in a closed regions of the chroma teens
you may not be able to to actually find
it in in your chromatin structure
although your in vitro that is where you
run them on amplicon or purified DNA
might give you good results when you
actually go ahead and you run your in
vivo experiment you may not get good
result because probably those target
sequences are in your closed chromatin
structure so you're interested to use to
use chromatin or chip and see how what
kind of a sensor respond we can get and
we can also use the system for
monitoring other type of casts enzymes
because or or cast like enzymes because
there's a lot of scientists and
researchers are developing similar
enzymes to cast that have different
efficiency or they may or they may not
require palm-like sequences so we can
also use those system on our CRISPR chip
so I'd like to summarize my my talk with
mentioning that combination of biology
and nanoelectronic can really provide us
with unique information about biological
molecules and biological events in our
body with this system we can actually
enhance the frequency of our measurement
and get real-time insight biological
event what are the enzyme activity
because you can enhance the frequencies
so quickly that you can actually see any
of enzyme interaction and if they
interact and release or you can monitor
those with electronic systems in
addition because in biology we're
usually dealing with charge molecules
like proteins or DNA with this
electronic system we have the ability to
control the mass transport of this dis
molecules we can bring them down to
where our surface where you have your
capturing molecules like like the cast
enzymes or the crispers complex and
improve your efficiency because
have to lie only on diffusion in this
system and you can do this without any
label without any chemistry which is
really powerful and this system can
really provide us with new information
which can help our understanding of
biological events happening inside us
with that I want to thank you for
listening and acknowledgement to my lab
members my collaborators and my support
and I would like to take any question
that you might have thank you very much
[Music]
thank you dr. Aron for that informative
presentation would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we'll see you next time goodbye